a few months ago i got an email from a
company called sparkmate they build
prototypes if you or your company has an
idea for a thing and the money to make
it they will build that thing for you
and they said to me tom we've got a bit
of spare time and want some publicity do
you have anything weird that you want
built so i looked through the long list
of impractical projects that are on my
ideas board and i realized that i could
answer a question that i've had since i
was very young
when i was a kid i watched a show called
captain scarlet and the mysterons it was
a tale of good versus evil the heroic
agents of spectrum fighting against the
mysterons from mars it was made with
puppets the hero character was
indestructible which is a brave
narrative choice and most people
remember one thing about it the weird
decision to do big scene transitions
like this
captain scarlett was made in the 60s
rerun in the 90s and kids like the young
version of me loved it it turns out
decades-old shows are still interesting
when you only have four tv channels and
no internet rewatching it as an adult
for this video first it's now in hd so
you can see the puppet strings and it is
brutally violent for a kid's show in the
first episode there's blood death by
gunshot and an alien replicant blowing
himself up and the production didn't shy
away from that by cutting into a
reaction shot of other characters the
special effects team literally put
explosives inside a puppet and blew it
up
wholesome family kids entertainment
there and the plots often make no sense
i tried to summarize the alien plan from
that first episode for this script and i
just gave up it makes no sense and it
keeps changing no one in the entire
episode human or alien act in any
rational way it's all just an excuse for
cool action scenes and explosions
and as a kid i didn't notice any of the
plot holes because there were cool
action scenes and explosions plus the
futuristic vehicles the most famous of
which was the spectrum pursuit vehicle
the spv according to the law of the show
it weighs eight tons but also somehow
floats its top speed is 200 miles an
hour and it comes equipped with rocket
cannons ejector seats and a jet pack
almost every episode a spectrum agent
would arrive at some apparently normal
location and an spv would be revealed in
overdramatic way
the team at sparkmate have not made me
an spv i'd love to have one but
unfortunately this is reality but
there's one other bizarre feature of
this thing that always stuck with me as
a kid and it's introduced in that first
episode by a couple of lines of dialogue
that show just how far voice acting in
kids shows has improved since the 60s i
see you have expert ratings on sbbs it
must be tricky facing backwards and
driving by tv monitor oh you get used to
it you drive the spv facing backwards
using a screen in the show the
explanation for that is that it's safer
if you're in a crash you stand a better
chance of survival if you're facing
backwards
that's true there are real world studies
that show that but from a production
perspective why would you do that it's
not required for the plot it just looks
confusing to have the background going
the wrong way and surely the characters
will get motion sick and confused by how
everything's turning it's such a weird
design choice it even shows up on the
toy versions if you open the doors here
the little action figures are facing
backwards even as a kid i thought surely
that's not a good idea so sparkmate have
made me a go-cart that's driven
backwards using a screen and that's
literally all i know i gave them that
brief showed them captain scarlet
episodes they said that sounds fun and
now i'm sitting in their office in an
industrial park on the outskirts of
paris about to see the results for the
first time so i can answer the question
i've had since i was a kid you can't
actually drive facing backwards right
oh wow
hope you like it wow
that's amazing ah so you have whole
television monitor there for all the
details is that
is that a game controller yeah it is
actually the first test that we did was
with this steering wheel and pedal and
we decided to switch from like a
steering wheel to an xbox uh gamepad why
because the challenge for us was to
create like a gamified experience of
like driving a vehicle just like in a
video game somehow and this camera is
what you're seeing in the front and we
even implemented some
that is annoyingly loud and i love it
so i've got to remember the cart is
facing this way yeah yeah let's let's
take it out and see
this this feels way more dangerous all
of a sudden
i also appreciate that this has like
full harness seat belts yeah i thought
we were going to make a tiny little
thing
that like i'd sit on and it would go at
low speed what's the what's the top
speed on this in this area we will reach
the 40 40 kilometer per hour but i guess
with a higher distance by the field we
can we could reach like 50 something 50
something for sure wait what's what's
this for this is the end brake
emergency brake you know because
sometimes things can
can happen you know if in there for
example if yeah if we lose control or we
just lose the controller
brake and yeah that will be fine so low
speed low speed test in the car park
yeah that's fine high speed test on the
track later yeah go for that let's do it
so we thought about different positions
we even sort of like driving like laid
on the at the bottom of the cart that
was obviously dangerous position so so
we went back to
a backward seated position i would say
it's just after some tests like with our
team trying what's the most comfortable
i would say we tried and we ended up in
this like um yeah average like position
okay there we go avoid no that's going
for some cars yeah i'm 100 aiming for
some cars though let's not do that
i'm aiming for the trucks which are this
way here we go yeah it's a bit confusing
at the beginning oh that's really
confused i don't like this
try to be a bit slower at the beginning
because yeah agree that's pretty yeah
that's that's pretty yeah yeah that's a
bit messing with your mind it really is
so we
actually used a very powerful motor like
a powerful servo motor to control the
direction system and we went through a
lot of like iterations and trials and
errors to configure the system also on
the mechanical part like how do we
install it how do we control it so that
it's smooth and that was a tricky part i
would say but once we had the propulsion
system the direction system then we were
like good to go to have fun all right
let's go down the road okay i got oh
that's too fast that's way too fast oh i
nearly went the wrong way i needed to
steer away from the van and i nearly
steered into the van gotta remember the
monitor you're focusing in the money
yeah the monitor oh that was a drain i
went straight over it keep your focus on
the monitor the monitor is all that
counts the minute i start
yeah the minute i start thinking about
the real world outside the monitor my
brain misfires i get left and right oh
that was a speed bump i got left and
right mixed up you're driving pretty
well i'm very impressed let's bring it
to a stop just here
i mean it's possible
but
for someone who hasn't played video
games in 15 20 years i mean i can do a
lap around here
it's just
confusing
to get used to it it's just confusing
that
the world is going one way but i have to
focus everything on the screen so the
visualization part we did a lot of
iterations we did a lot of tests a lot
of coding and
as you can imagine the main problem was
latency
so we like we had to fight whenever we
tried different things but we always had
to fight latency we thought about like
yeah drones uh
vr we ended up i think the the version
that we have right now is using webrtc
uh like from a web browser communicating
through socket to a android engine
that's the most uh i would say advanced
we we we went
on the vr part so i asked the team for
uh a steering wheel and we have a
hastily jerry rigged steering wheel here
because it's just a different type of
controller and i have spent way more
time with one of these and i have with a
game controller you all ready all right
let's see how this we're turning right
oh that's nice uh yeah here we go that's
it like oh okay yep okay right focus on
the screen anyone coming no one coming
right so we turn left out of here
slowly here slow
that's good yeah you've got the
sensitivity right now that's it all
right here we go bit of speed
[Music]
focus on the screen
what i did there what i did there was i
turned right
when i should have turned left
you okay we're just fighting man we just
avoided this
the the the good news is that the cart
works
and
uh it goes to speed
what happened you were not focused on
the screen i was very focused on the
screen and all i need to do was turn
left and my brain turned right
wow that's confusing well i i hate to
say let's go to the track on that but um
we should we should we should probably
go to the track yeah because i don't
like the fact that we're doing this
around cars now i'm i've i've got lead
foot i i was so confident fortunately
nothing bad happened yeah you you just
dropped back we got scared yep and
that's it that's yeah you built a strong
car we're fine let's um
let's go to the track
power on
lights on a little bit of acceleration
okay there we go that is
twitchy all right we're fine concentrate
on the screen tom come straight in the
screen make it round the track
there we go yeah
there we go right good a little bit of
straight here line it up hey this is
working whoa that's a little bit off but
we're okay we're okay we're good now
we're on the straight right floor it
let's see what this thing can do
whoa
okay that's fine that's fine that's fine
break
yeah and right around here
break into the corner
well that's a strong left turn that's a
strong left turn but i went the right
way the correct way i didn't go the
right way went the correct way
[Applause]
nearly
i can't believe i'm saying this but um
it works
like
i was expecting to get motion sick i was
expecting to to fall over i was
expecting to be like this old this old
puppet show was was terrible and
yeah you can absolutely drive like that
like my problems were sight lines
and not being used to the controls and
like this big a quickly jerry-rigged
wheel but you're saying that cars should
be like this
oh i'm not saying it's an improvement on
driving forwards but if i'd crashed i
would have been safer
this is it works thank you folks
we've answered a question i had for 25
years thank you
[Applause]
you